vous avez fait secretstory vous avez
fait les anges french tripes il ya une
étiquette télé réalité j'imagine pèse
encore aujourd'hui oui c'est vrai quand
on vous voit dans la rue vous êtes
encore la fille de téléralité parle
pratiquement tout le temps de ça tout le
temps tout le temps ça ne marche pas ça
vous dérange pas non pas du tout mais
aujourd'hui vous voulez monter une
marque vous avez créé une marque c'est
ça j'ai ma marque de chaussures depuis
maintenant deux ans ouais donc je
précise max chaussures ont dessiné
modèles ont fait produire alpin peut
plus faire mouche ou ouais moi n'ont pas
bien ok je disais qu'on dessine les
modèles on les fait produire voilà est
donc maintenant je les commercialise
uniquement sur internet mais mais mais
pour vous maintenant dans l'idée c'est
de toute manière je serai toujours
toujours une personne de télé réalité
donc je vais en joue et je vais gagner
de l'argent là dessus je vais tout faire
là dessus ou maintenant pour vous c'est
un poids et vous vous et c'est vraiment
de décrocher le boulet alors très
sincèrement je pense que c'est une
erreur de vouloir se dire ah j'ai pas
fais télé franchement je renie moi je
crache pas sur le sur ça parce que c'est
quelque chose qui aujourd'hui a fait que
je peux développer tous les projets j'ai
pu mettre ma famille à l'abri
voilà pour moi la télé réalité c'est pas
une honte je les fait j'étais très très
bien j'ai été moi donc personnellement
qu vendu on me dise oui tu étais dans
secret story ça me dérange pas mais vous
rendez compte que pour les gens pardon
mal moi j'ai dit tout ce que j'entends
j'entends des choses j'entends vous
aimez la double étiquette aujourd'hui
c'est la fille café latté vérité un peu
bimbo et qui en plus est marié femme est
avec un joueur de foot de manchester
united
donc là on est vraiment dans toute
l'image de la bimbo avec un mec de foot
là on est vraiment dans tous cas de
clichés ça c'est dur à porter pas de nom
pas du tout pas du tout non
aujourd'hui cheikh un footballeur oui
pas de souci mais cette étiquette avait
pas dur à porter pour moi parce que je
l'assumé entièrement et j'ai vraiment
aucun problème avec ça on me dit est ce
qu'ils parlent vous êtes marié le
catering ça c'est pas su ça eh ben vous
l'êtes je suis pas obligé de mater photo
non mais vous pouvez le dire oui et pas
de citations mais bon
il est magnifique et vous êtes
magnifique
guillaume est question peut-être et vous
pourrez tout su poser des questions sur
effectivement est ce qu'on peut se
dégager de l'image de télé réalité ou
pas ça agaçant mais vous avez l'air de
dire que c'est pas un problème d'être
des traîtres
comment dire de d'avoir fait une
téléréalité doit l'assumer aussi peut-on
donc pour guillaume c'est non non non
non on peut pas en papa vous serez
toujours la fille de tes l'arrêter mais
c'est pas mal je trouve que ça à nouveau
c'est l'époque et slc là aujourd'hui non
moi j'ai une question par rapport à est
ce que c'est vrai que je vais vous
parler ça fait un peu brutale de
finances
est ce que c'est vrai que vous gagnez
aujourd'hui entre 60 et 100 mille euros
par mois d'accord donc ça c'est grâce à
la télé-réalité c'est grâce à la
télé-réalité mais elle est formidable
c'est la vérité moi j'adore les gens qui
disent la vérité qui disent les choses
et encore une fois c'est pas de l'argent
volé si on vous le donne c'est que c'est
vous rapporter au moins cet argent là
ces crèmes à magali bengali pour vous
effectivement on peut dégager d'une
image de tes vérités mois parken
receveur j'en connais aucune que
j'embrasse et qu'on recevra bientôt
alors on peut s'en dégage et moi je
pense à partir du moment où justement on
l'assumé on cherche pas le cacher oui
c'est à dire que quand on cherche à le
cacher ça pose un frein je prends
l'exemple par exemple et c'est vraiment
pas méchant ce que je vais dire mais de
capucine qu'à ma cousine et et que
j'adore mais c'est vrai que quand on
veut absolument pas pas mais se mettre à
côté puis voilà je fais pas datées
manquerait pas fait je veux blocs et
cetera je pense que ça peut être plus un
poids que justement qu'un qu'il assume
qui va en faire quelque chose de positif
qui va développer qui grandit quand on
parle par exemple de mélanie et qu'on
dise est un cliché elle est femme de
footballeur mais en soit si c'est un
cliché que les femmes de footballeurs
elle n'a pas besoin de travailler
elle n'a pas besoin de faire de société
attend d'elle bourg et au netbook il y
avait une société où dedans il ya la
sublime talent machin il ya les acteurs
et les gens de télé réalité cette jeune
fille qui est chez vous elle est dans
les gens de télé réalité oui mais c'est
là qu'elle gagne son argent n est pas
dans les gens qui ont une marque qui
vend des chaussures filiales
et concret mais en fait je suis désolé
j'ai pas compris la question
mathieu pour vous faire oublier
on peut faire oublier ya un seul cas
c'est simple vous l'avez dit c'est quand
l'hymne receveur et je vous dire ses
tresses et la une de vogue
voilà moi je travaille beaucoup avec
évidemment des magazines avec des
agences de publicité et vous avez
énormément de follower plein de gens une
amende follower sauf quand je vais sur
instagram et je regarde qui suit ces
gens là la seule suivi par des
rédactions de mode crédible par des
agences de publicité crédible c'est
caroline receveur les autres n'ont pas
une fois pas une fois vous étudié par
des maquilleuses des gens d'ici des gens
de la télé réalité des jeunes beaucoup
mais pas du tout malheureusement pas
pour l'instant par les vrais
décisionnaires de magasins est ce que
vous pensez qu'un jour voilà c'est bien
la télé arrêtez-vous gagner beaucoup
d'argent que vous êtes très heureuse
mais ce que vous pensez que du coup un
jour ben vous pourrez peut-être avoir
accès mais peut-être au cinéma à faire
la une de vogue à la mode a à toutes ces
choses là peut-être vous en avez rêvé
est ce que vous n'avez pas regarder trop
à court terme et à long terme sur une
carrière comme a pu le faire qu'une
receveur alors personnellement je pense
que tout est une question d'opportunité
tu te retrouves au bon endroit au bon
moment
oui tu accroches à la personne vers qui
peut faire plein de choses plus qu à
votre époux
moi je veux continuer à développer la
marque de chaussures je veux ouvrir
d'autres choses j'aurais le pape pour
l'instant parce que tant que ce n'est
pas concret vous referiez la télé
réalité
ça dépend ça dépend de moi une émission
adaptée à moi enfin taper sur vous et
adapté à moi une énigme
une émission qui me correspond oui je le
ferai maintenant je veux dire la vérité
la totale vérité je suis quelqu'un de
vrai ça veut dire que je ne préfère pas
retourner dans quelque chose dans le
sens où moi j'ai mon petit garçon et
j'ai pas envie les options des teams
laisse que des regrets ce que vous avez
à regret vous avez fait les enjeux
qu'elle coûte que vous avez montré que
vous êtes-vous dit j'aurais pas dû
c'était pas moi ça non pas du tout aucun
pas du tout aucun pas du tout moi je moi
je fais confiance aux productions et à
partir du moment où ils ont voulu
montrer quelque chose de moi il n'y a
aucun problème
alors là non si je vois quelque chose un
petit peu louche et que je sais pas du
tout ça je le dirai mais moi j'ai rien à
dire mais production mondiale les
fennecs ne peut pas faire oublier mais
de toute façon qu'est-ce qui va le faire
oublier
quand on regarde leur instagram c'est de
la télé réalité apprendre comment parler
raconte tout bon que vous êtes pas dit
vous étiez marier mais bon on en voit
quand même suffisamment pour être
rassasié quand on vous suit enfin pour
moi voilà il reste même quand ils sont
sur instagram et qu'ils ont des grands
projets de développement de marque etc
ça reste quand même des candidats de
télé réalité et c'est aussi pour ça que
ça marche parce que les gens veuillent
les suivent et c'est pour ça moi je dis
arrêtez de suivre ces gens là si vous
voulez pas si vous êtes effaré de voir
que quelqu'un comme ça gagnent entre 60
et 100 mille euros pour faire quoi une
peau photo avec une chaussure soir était
de les suivre c'est tout voilà parce que
la télé réalité c'est pas sa nation et
non mais je trouve que mélanie c'est
beaucoup plus sain sa démarche que par
exemple quelqu'un comme jennifer qui
pète un plomb dès qu'on lui parle de la
star ac
il fallait assumer assumée elle assume à
fond ali va continuer
oui je vois pas où est le problème est
pourquoi je voudrais faire absolument le
problème il est peut-être l'avenir
c'était un moment donné et on va tous
désiré pour le faire
c'est qu'en ce moment fort normand les
gens achètent beau chaussures avec tout
le respect que j'ai pour vous pour vous
parce qu'ils vous aiment qui est en
panne peut-être plus que pour la
chaussure
il ya un moment donné vous allez un
petit peu fané et est ce que la
chaussure c'est la ville et par l'ancien
animateur télé mais c'est déjà je dis
toujours me fasse un sportif c'est pas
mal comme on fabrique c'est vrai que ce
sont des métiers d'image passés comme
tout le monde est à la télé réalité
c'est quoi ça tremplin à la naissance à
projet et a pris retombera et donc sans
les choix qu'ils ont fait rien n'est pas
honteux mais il faut l'assumer à la
raison d'assumer nos différences entre
ceux qui ont fait de la télé réalité par
exemple il ya dix ans comme karine ferri
laurent ournac etc
on en parle absolument plus en fait
d'être en couple est encore temps
j'aimerais donner à notre invité voilà
tout le monde de la mode par rapport à
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure moi
personnellement ça fait maintenant 50 g
par fait de télé je garde les ti cats et
j'ai aucun problème si je vous montrais
les personnes qui viennent acheter mes
chaussures vous seriez très choquée j'ai
fait des pop up store j'en ai fait deux
à paris oui c'est pas du tout des
petites de 16 ans il ya des femmes
il ya les dames bien plus mûr il ya de
tout pour moi là dessus je m'inquiète
pas du tout à partir du moment où mon
produit j'y crois voilà le vent
correctement je leur raconte pas de
salade du moulin comme nettement non
nagées plus tard j'ai pu temps et comme
c est un aimant et été très honnête
c'est quoi la marque des chaussures
sinon bah là n'ont pas l'eau on n'a pas
le temps de le dire mais comme ça c'est
dit tu seras pas venu pour rien aussi